Let's look at some of
the things in the back.
MIKE: OK.
Just straight back here, Mike.
MIKE: Oh, wow.
Man, look at all these records.
Lots of records.
MIKE: This is it.
Yeah, handpicked.
I mean, this is
like serious stuff.
MIKE: OK.
So this is all like-- this
is a curated collection?
Yes.
The items I'm drawn
to happen to have
a good connection
with rock and roll,
from posters to
the clothes I wear.
It makes me feel great.
That jukebox work?
Have you had it working ever?
Yeah.
You know, the tone
arm is broken.
MIKE: It's a beautiful piece.
[rock music]
It's a Rock-Ola
jukebox, a piece of art.
It's a classic period, 1948.
This is obviously
an iconic model.
Yeah.
MIKE: All the soldiers
that came home
from the war, that were
celebrating with their ladies
and everything--
I mean, this was what would
have been in the tavern.
And they were lighting it up.
And it lights up.
So it's--
MIKE: It is beautiful.
I mean, do you have to
actually open the door to put
the record on and help it?
- Yeah.
You put it on, and the
disk spins, and that's it.
MIKE: Yeah.
I mean, with that
said, I love it.
I don't know if you're going
to do anything with it.
But I'd be a player
at like 1,100 bucks.
Can you do 15?
Having a store in Nashville
has made me change gears
on the way I look at things.
I'm going to do 1,500.
And the reason I'm
going to do that
is because we can rent this.
We're in the antique business.
But we're also finding ourselves
in the prop rental business.
It's old microphones.
It's old guitars.
It's old banjos.
It's old jukeboxes.
Because we have a lot
of musicians down there
that even want to
use them for a video.
Or they want to use them
just for still photography.
It's the gift that
keeps on giving.
- Let's do it.
- All right.
It was a beautiful piece.
But my association
with it is finished.
I like this piece right here--
United States Air
Force, 8th Engineering.
You know, it's got
the bomber pin on it.
This was a piece that someone
put together as a memento
for their years in the service.
Do you remember
where you found this?
Yeah, a flea market.
That's cool.
This is a very personal piece--
United States Air Force,
8th Engineering Division.
It's got his wings on there.
Some of it's hand carved.
It says victory on the bottom.
I like how they
incorporated in the plane.
See how they've incorporated
that pin right there?
Yeah.
MIKE: And this one here.
Here's a plane
getting shot down.
I mean, it's patriotic.
It's folk art.
It's militaria.
There's so much going on here.
It's very cool.
Can I make you an offer on this?
- Yeah, maybe.
Like 125?
You know, that's a
pretty special piece,
the outsider artist part of it.
- Yeah, I know.
That's what I love about it too.
I don't know, maybe 150.
- How about 140?
- OK.
- All right.
- We'll do it.
Thanks man.
- And a haircut.
- All right.
[laughter]
Hey, Mike, I want to
show you this bike
I've had for many years.
- Oh yeah.
That's a Schwinn Phantom, man.
- Yeah.
I bought it from a
friend at a yard sale
that I went to high school with.
This was Schwinn's deluxe
bike from 1949 to 1959.
They made it in black.
They made it in red.
They made it in green.
This is the black Phantom.
Just the name alone, the
mystique, the allure,
the cool factor--
back then and now--
is the same.
I'd do 750 bucks on it.
If the chain guard
was on it, and it
was in a little better shape,
it would bring that number up.
How about 850?
Why don't we just
do an even eight?
All right, Mike, you got it.
All right, man.
I appreciate it.
Just for the hell of
it, I got to know,
how much was it
at the yard sale?
50 bucks.